[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi et 4 juin
une passion qu'il en est au canada
l'yvelinois ecclésiaste lombard est de
cinéma et a déjà produit deux films le
dernier sera projeté à paris à la fin de
la semaine le temps dans l'après midi le
théâtre montansier devenu un studio
radio le journaliste franck ferrand a
enregistré en public plusieurs émissions
autour de la ville de versailles et
partez pour un voyage dans le temps
château de breteuil à l'époque de henry
de breteuil 2/8 marquis de la famille
les costumes et tenues seront de sortie
on commence avec du cinéma samedi se
tenait le 8e festival les clés du cinéma
une après-midi de projections autour de
courts métrages pour cette nouvelle
édition une quinzaine de films étaient
projetés
marylène et a pu financer glisser parmi
les spectateurs un retour pour certains
à guillaume le ville est sélectionné
pour la deuxième fois
il présentait arthur rimbaud pour
inspirer de son enfant sur l'île de la
réunion
une histoire d'amitié entre un poète de
la rue et d'un petit garçon
les enfants ils ont une nature elle une
candeur auquel on n'est pas forcément
habitué parce qu'on a l'habitude de
travailler avec d'oligo c'est à dire
nous on est plein d gola les adultes
enfants un peu moins pas tout de suite
ils ont raison si on lui tend dans le
film enfin il était
les comédiens de 8 ans les clés du
cinéma ont à nouveau fait le plan près
de 200 spectateurs ont répondu présents
pour cette nouvelle édition lancée en
2012 le festival accueille des
réalisateurs locaux de l'hexagone et
internationaux on demande aux gens qui
ont des films qui sont de 80 fiction
animation clip ou films autres sauf ceux
qui mentent elles qui créent du type
post de candidature on a un jury de
présélection
j en ligne note les films donc ça nous
fait une présélection qu'on propose à la
ville des clés key qui valide la
sélection et qui organise la sucre pour
cette huitième édition 13 films étaient
en compétition six prix ont été remis à
l'issue des trois heures de projection
et le premier prix du jury a été
attribué à déborah hassoun pour ne
demande pas ton chemin c'est l'histoire
d'inès 31 ans qui souhaite quitter son
psy et devant l'ampleur de la tâche elle
décide de se faire aider par un autre
psy extrait de la première séance
j'aurais dû me douter que ça
fonctionnerait pas il m'a demandé si je
voulais m'allonger ou m'asseoir moi j'ai
pris le divan mâchait pas vraiment mais
c'est l'image qui me plaisait mais j'ai
mal au dos à l'horizontale et j'arrive
pas à lui dire
les roues sont à la côte n'arrive plus à
pala centimes ivoire était non
c'est bizarre quand même et tout ce que
je vais raconter que les toutes les
névroses je suis tellement parler car ça
sort pas après le roman le film xav et
senio a adapté son sixième ouvrage pour
le cinéma dans des maisons suis jacques
meyer un jeune homme qui se réveille à
l'hôpital avec une amnésie partielle
un jeune homme en quête d'eau
obsessionnel pardon de justice dans
mettez une ville gangrénée le film sera
projeté à fontenay le fleury le 11 juin
prochain et un extrait de la bande
annonce
ce pseudo justice qui n'a aucune
légitimité pour faire la loi doit
appliquer la justice
je pense effectivement les
là seulement pour les jo mais dangereux
que ceux qui le combat dans cette vidéo
ok nation en deuil et on la comprend et
xav et senio était d'ailleurs l'invité
du journal de grégory et canale ce mardi
4 rejoint son interview est à retrouver
sur notre site internet tv 78 points
comme on continue et du cinéma avec nos
invités une touche de bad boys un
soupçon de flic de beverly hills
les influences qui ont mené à welcome to
montreal la dernière production et le
dernier scénario de l'illinois
ecclésiaste long bail est avec nous au
plateau accompagné de trois autres
membres de l'équipe du film jason
caramel vous êtes le réalisateur on d
andrea berdych kova et daniel podor vous
êtes comédiens bonjour à tous les quatre
alors avec les a selon bat déjà vers
vous comment est née l'idée du film
or l'idée du film est venu
officiellement en 2013 après avoir fait
quelques apparitions dans des émissions
télévisées qui ont fait de moi un petit
personnage comique et beaucoup de
membres de familles de l'entourage ont
poussé à faire une comédie policière
vu mon personnage apple comme icare dans
la vraie vie donc je me suis orientée
vraiment dans un genre qui réunit qui
rassemble qui fait rire tout le monde
qui est la comédie policière
et justement la comédie policière on
l'aura compris avec les tenues de
d'entre vous j'ai été comme tous
montréal c'est une comédie policière qui
raconte l'histoire de désiré barreau me
tendit la cfu même agent de la bac
parisienne qui est recruté par le
service de police de montréal
quand on en vient à jouer avec denis
complètement différent alors en fait
dans le cadre d'une collaboration entre
les polices francophone il y a il faut
savoir qu'il existe ce qu'on appelle
francopol c'est en fait c'est un comité
des changes entre les coupes aux listes
francophones
et puis 7 il ya un petit mélange de
fiction bien évidemment c'est de là
qu'il m'est venue cette idée et pouvoir
mettre un petit peu une touche une
touche de réalité mais aussi un peu de
fiction pour vos vraiment faire
intéresser les téléspectateurs et avant
de continuer vous regardez un extrait de
la bande annonce
agendée à les barreaux la gagne à gauche
on est vrai criminel s'entraîne
terroriser des commerçants ici un
mondial mio ça se paye la protection
calme revient il faut pas le maillot
libé arrêté un suspect ce matin même le
nom de la femme du général et jean
carbonel vous enseignez donc la
réalisation
qu'est ce qui vous a plu dans ce projet
à la base
on ne sait notre deuxième projet
ensemble avec ce truc
on se connaissait déjà un deuxième
scénario j'ai dit pourquoi pas encore
pigé toutefois s'intéresse à une comédie
policière avec beaucoup de personnes
beaucoup de goût du défi comme projet
comparé comparativement au 1er mai j'ai
embarqué dans le deuxième parce que
qu'ils assènent confiance puis il
travaille bien ça travaille bien
ensemble en communion se communique bien
au fait que j'imagine autour l'agent peu
survoltée
ou alors est ce que dans une comédie au
contraire il faut être super sérieux
pour éviter que ça parte dans tous les
sens et en fait je leur ai hâte en fac
c'est sûr que je dois garder mon sérieux
il faut qu'on rentre dans l'étape quand
faut être un peu en discipline c'est sûr
qu'il ya des journées où ce que les gens
le savaient mais jeune actif d'être
gentil mais avec un peu de discipline
mais malgré que quand c'est le temps
certains ont des cornes on s'amuse mais
sinon pour ce badge et 13 mai c'est ce
que oui un peu de spleen surtout c'est
la comédie fait que des roues et des
fous rires il y en a eu depuis c'est ce
que des fois franchement je m'en empêche
les gens n'y paraît que je pouvais pas
m'en passer
andré interne du covan un épaulement
vous donc vous jouez des policiers vous
êtes même le commandant de la brigade
est-ce qu'il a fallu s'adapter à une
vision française ou ecclésiaste avait
bien cerné le monde québécois
il avait bien cerné est vraiment que je
joue à ma façon
donc j'avais carte blanche cette annonce
est cessé la veille ecclésiale et
jackson c'était ça pouvait facilement
par rapport au scénario sans avoir
offert les deux est ce qu'il est arrivé
avec une division jeux pour tout
attendre avec une vision et vous annonce
mais ça se passe pas du tout comme ça
chez nous
est ce que les comédiens ont aussi leur
mot à dire c'était bien monté webb a
écrit dès que j'ai lu le scénario avec
les ja c'est sûr qu'il ya des trucs que
j'ai suggéré parce que france et québec
une petite différence au niveau du
langage ça qu'on l'a adapté pour être
capable d'être un petit peu universel
mais plus on voit dans la bande annonce
que c'est surtout vous qui avez le goût
du comique et mais andrea vous avez pu
aussi mettre une petite touche d'humour
pour mettre l'humour québécois en avant
j'ai beaucoup aimé l'expérience
au début j'avais un rôle totalement de
serveuse et après de jésus n'est que les
incendies avaient peut-être que tu
prennes joue le rôle de policier et j'ai
dit oui tout de suite dit beaucoup d'un
moment de fou rire et c'était vraiment
amusant quoi c'est une belle expérience
ou si je vais lors d'une policière
et je suis sûr acheter un petit quelque
chose je suis dans ma mère m'a vu faire
justement le tournage ahmadi quand il
était petit il rêvait d'être policière
visait la boucle était bouclée
vous avez dû faire beaucoup de
recherches ou c'est un monde que vous
connaissez déjà vous avez déjà des
envies d'ailleurs
à vrai dire c'est mon deuxième projet
deuxième film indépendant je tiens à
préciser
donc ça a été à vrai dire il ya eu un an
de recherche de casting et ça m'a pris à
vrai dire un an le temps d'observation
parce que le tournage a débuté en 2015
officiellement en juin 2015
mais entre eux juin 2014 et juin 2015 a
été un an de recherche allant de
recherche de comédiens d'acteurs donc il
ya 200 participants et 200 participants
à 95% ce sont - qui disons que qui est
allé les chercher les chercher et puis
après par ford grâce au bouche à oreille
j'ai voulu vraiment les acteurs
crédible dans la rolls le policier pour
daniel pots de vin j'ai voulu que quand
j'ai vu sans l'avoir vu physiquement
lorsque j'ai vu ces photos je lui parle
au téléphone je me suis dit quelle
vitesse je vais faire un bon commandant
etc c'est comme ça c'est ça s'est bien
passé et ça s'est fait de façon suivante
le film le fils va être projeté sur le
territoire français le 7 juin prochain
mais il a déjà été projeté en novembre
2010 est au canada quelles ont été les
réactions
en fait sur notre page facebook
justement il va avoir un vidéo qui veut
diffuser au crin et kleiza le cpo capes
mais en gros en gros le film a nui un
bel accueil par le public québécois à
montréal ainsi qu'à québec la capitale
provinciale de la province du québec
il a été très bien accueilli les
spectateurs ont même été jusqu'à nous
dire on attend le deuxième
nous ce qu'on peut répondre actuellement
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore au
deuxième mais c'est sûr que beaucoup de
demandes mais on n'est pas encore arrivé
à là mais on promet que si nous avons
cette fois ci les moyens des grosses
maisons de production franco québécoise
en tout cas nous serons ouverts pourquoi
pas un deuxième volume on ne sait pas
pour l'instant mais en france ce qu'ils
veulent vraiment voir la réaction des
gens sur notre page facebook comme le
disait en vidéo ou ce qui est un peu
[Musique]
petit vidéo qu'ils ont peut-être 1 45
secondes une minute mais on voit les
réactions du monde en sortant de la
salle
c'est bien noté c'est vrai ce qu'ils
disent et ce qu'ils sont et où je peux
prédire et le menu aussi c'est peut-être
d'aller voir le film
est ce qu'il ya un endroit où on peut le
voir ce qu'est ce que le 7 juin les gens
peuvent se déplace en chinant javits
tous mes amis connaissances mais je
pourrais dire même si c'est pas le terme
approprié le compatriote yvelinois des
yvelines des quatre coins des yvelines à
venir très nombreux à me venir me
soutenir en tant qu yvelinois j'ai
grandi aux mureaux donc au bureau on
nous connaît en tant que chasseur the
stars en tant que divers chose en tout
cas qu'il vienne me soutenir et soutenir
toute l'église amis comme est comme une
famille à présent qu'ils viennent nous
soutenir et ce sera grandiose je promets
des grosses surprises est une grande
première pas comme les autres et donc
pour toutes les infos pour l'épreuve la
première c'est le vendredi 7 juin c'est
à paris au studio des ursulines et c'est
pour will come to montréal merci à tous
les quatre d'être venu on termine avec
le cinéma et on parle maintenant de la
radio le théâtre montansier a changé de
visage le temps dans l'après midi
franck ferrand étaient présents pour un
enregistrement le dimanche de joie
l'écrivain et journaliste s'intéresse à
versailles dont cinq émissions pour
radio classique et véronique ithurbide
et patrick jacques de dixmude nous
rencontrer franck ferrand raconte sur
radio classique
depuis le théâtre montansier à
versailles franck ferrand raconte la
grande histoire de versailles celle de
la ville pour radio classique le
journaliste a enregistré 5 émission
entièrement dédié à la cité royale
une première sur cette antenne nous
allons commencer par un sujet j'allais
dire d'actualité en tout cas de
résonance
mémorielle puisqu'il s'agit de la paix
de 1919 et ce traité de versailles le
fameux traité de versailles
on va raconter les circonstances de la
signature de ce traité
et puis ensuite ce sera le grand
déroulement de l'histoire versaillaise
de la création de la ville par louis xiv
aux grands noms de l'histoire inspirée
par la cité franck ferrand retraçant
versa et qui le passionne le journaliste
qui a vécu trois ans en l'an 2000 je
commençais à envisager d'écrire sur
versailles avait énormément de choses
que j'avais à dire que levet accumulées
depuis des années des années comme une
documentation phénoménal j'étais devenu
l'ami des conservateurs du château
j'avais beaucoup de d'ouverture dans
certains fonds d'archivés bref il
fallait que j'écrive et je me suis dit
que le mieux ce serait de le faire ici
même pour écouter les émissions il
faudra patienter encore quelques jours
première diffusion le 10 juin à 9 heures
et 14 heures sur radio classique
au centre de musique baroque de
versailles on peut chanter dès l'âge de
4 ans en entrant au jardin musical ce
sont les premières classes de la
maîtrise une séance d'activités est
prévue chaque semaine le mercredi par
petit groupe de 15 enfants
les dossiers de candidatures peuvent
être déposées jusqu'à la fin du match la
fin du mois de juin deux séances de
rencontres et d'essai seront organisées
au mois de septembre quelques précisions
de deux escrocs mal à l'administrateur
de la maîtrise avant d'écouter un court
extrait d'une répétition
petit à petit ils vont découvrir voilà
le champ immense de la musique à travers
toute une série de petits jeux dans
lesquels à la fois la chanson le rythme
les jeux corporels vont être très mise
en avant
donc pour les enfants c'est très
agréable parce que c'est très ludique et
à travers tout cela en fait un
sensiblement au cours de cette année de
cette deuxième année ensuite eh bien ils
vont acquérir d'une part le plaisir de
la musique puisque ça avant tout le but
mais aussi un certain nombre de notions
la mélodie la reconnaissance des timbres
les rythmes etc
ah ah
[Musique]
à
je vous propose maintenant de remonter
le temps direction l'année 1900 le
château de breteuil était la propriété
de henry de breteuil le huitième marquis
de la famille c'est une période
marquante pour l'histoire du château
bonjour christophe leray bonjour alors
vous êtes scénographe en charge
notamment de cette journée
déjà pourquoi une troisième édition
choisir 1900 alors eh bien parce que ça
devient rendez vous les deux premières
éditions ont eu beaucoup beaucoup de
succès et bien nous nous sommes dit que
la période aussi était passionnante
c'est une sorte d'âge d'or pour le
château de breteuil alors pourquoi pas
prolonger développer d'autres
thématiques pour cette troisième édition
une période d'âge d'or liés à l'histoire
notamment autour du marquis ou 6 liée à
la société le confort moderne qui évolue
un petit peu les deux je pense que tout
est lié profondément c'est un contexte
vraiment de grande effervescence 1900
paris est la capitale du monde il y à
l'exposition universelle des grandes
innovations techniques
la mode est
voilà il ya un grand dynamisme et
justement à breteuil on trouve aussi
cette effervescence alors la famille de
breteil vivait entre paris et breteuil
et justement dans ces années dans ce
début de xxème siècle de grands travaux
sont entrepris
on apporte le confort moderne
l'électricité l'eau courante
les jardins sont complètement revu donc
il ya vraiment une période de vie où on
reçoit c'est un âge d'or effectivement
c'est après que trois ans après il ya
toujours autant de choses à montrer à
faire découvrir
ah oui on continue de développer les
thématiques et là particulièrement on va
axer cette troisième édition sur les
arts de vivre et puis les loisirs
également alors pourquoi ces différentes
notre époque
ou au contraire montré que 1900 il était
déjà bien avancé on est toujours dans
cette dynamique
effectivement on peut faire le lien avec
notre époque et se rendre compte que et
bien ce 20ème siècle début de xxème
siècle il y a donc sans 19 ans n'est pas
si lointain de notre époque
en tout cas on peut avoir un certain
confort
aujourd'hui mais finalement et quand on
s'attarde un petit peu sur l'histoire de
l'antiquité jusqu'à nos jours finalement
les hommes ont les mêmes aspirations les
mêmes craintes les mêmes peurs les mêmes
désirs les mêmes douleurs donc il ya
quelque chose finalement d'intemporel
est de faire de l'histoire vivante c'est
aussi une façon de faire résonner les
époques entre elles avec la nôtre de
l'histoire du monde qui à être fait par
des animateurs a entre guillemets c'est
ce qu'ils vont animer cette journée
ce sont des professionnels ou des
amateurs avisés alors il ya les deux il
va y avoir une véritable médiation
culturelle et l'a donc l'équipe du
château de breteuil et très mobilisés
donc vous avez des guides conférenciers
qui véritablement vont sortir un petit
peu de leur rôle habituel pour incarner
des personnages et animer des ateliers
il y aura des comédiens est aussi et là
c'est une part très importante de la
journée
nous avons des figurants des
reconstitueurs qui sont des passionnés
de cossu et qui adore justement se
plonger dans dans une période précise
réaliser leur tenue et la faire vivre
justement en incarnant le temps d'une
journée en situation un personnage vous
parlez des costumes justement que
certains les ont fait eux mêmes qu est
ce qui t les codes l'époque comment
est-ce qu'on peut être sûr que c'est une
tenue qui représente bien 1900 elle a
réuni à une grande variété mais il ya
surtout des des grands des grands
classiques c'est-à-dire que pour les
hommes il y a une tenue qui est
constitué d'un costume trois pièces
donc là bon c'est quelque chose d'assez
d'assez courant vous avez une chemise et
un gilet un pantalon pourrait rajouter
la veste en fait on va porter une tenue
en fonction du moment de la journée et
c'est la même chose pour les femmes il
ya des tenues de jour des tenues de
soirée
il faut dire qu'en 1900 quand même
les femmes portent toujours des corps
c'est donc la notion de confort et versé
l'année à savoir exactement mais nous
avons de grands couturiers comme paul
poiret qui ont nouvelle conception du
corps de la femme et qui vont justement
petit à petit essayer d'alléger les
silhouettes d'apporter une certaine
sensualité une certaine féminité
vous avez parlé de paul poiret mais
aussi et voilà ce qui se passe dans ces
journées pardon c'est que on met en
avant des personnages illustres alors il
ya les personnages du château ceux qui
sont passés il y aura aussi une certaine
gabrielle chanel pallier au château
milliers à l'époque tout à fait alors on
fait avec les reconstitueurs nous avons
la volonté de mettre en scène la famille
leurs amis et puis aussi des personnages
de l'époque du contexte donc gabrielle
chanel comme on va avoir une animation
théâtrale autour de la mode notamment
animé par paul poiret par la comédienne
réjane on s'était dit que le clin d'oeil
pouvait être tout à fait intéressant
puisque en 1900 gabrielle chanel a
autour de 18 19 ans elle sort du couvent
excoffon non ce n'est pas encore coco
mais on est aux balbutiements et là
quand même des des vrais prédispositions
pour la couture et est donc c'est très
intéressant de rencontrer un personnage
à l'aube et bien d'une immense carrière
alors ces personnages illustres il est
aussi des instants musicaux
un trio le piano trotteurs oui nous
avons du théâtre de la musique cette
année on est ravis de les accueillir
c'est un trio qui est qui est très très
talentueux ce sont trois trois jeunes
personnes il y a deux pianistes et une
pianiste et la particularité c'est qu'il
joue des morceaux d'époque
donc là on entendra des airs de debussy
de gabriel fauré des camille saint saëns
de koné tout ce qu'on connaît
effectivement oui ça reste des airs
quand même accessible et qui reste dans
une mémoire collective et surtout ce
sont des personnes qui qui pousse le
vice jusqu'à restaurer les instruments
d'époque
et donc quand on se dit justement un
piano c'est assez intransportable assez
contraignant eux ont réussi ce pari fou
d'avoir justement ces instruments qui
peuvent être déplacées et donc il peut y
avoir plusieurs spots tout au long de la
journée
enfin c'est un travail formidable il
aime à la fois leurs instruments ils les
restaure et puis il les joue avec avec
beaucoup de talent alors la
particularité de ces journées là c'est
qu'on puisse le château tout le château
est mis à contribution ne va rien rater
ont plus de l'histoire peut-être presque
architectural du site c'est vrai et je
tiens à préciser vraiment que qu'il
fasse beau ou qu'il pleuve toutes les
activités seront maintenues fin dont
quasiment l'intégralité peut-être que
les courses de sacs en toile de jute ne
pourront pas se faire comme ça peut être
compliqué mais dans le château dans les
cuisines dans les dépendances dans
l'orangerie donc là les activités seront
vraiment répartis sur la totalité du
domaine et il ya vraiment de quoi
contenter petits et grands on a parlé
des costumes de ceux qui animent
mais il y aura peut-être des passionnés
dans le public est ce que eux aussi
peuvent venir costumés et oui là
justement nous souhaitons avec le
marquis de breteuil ouvrir cet événement
un large public
c'est vraiment cette volonté de créer un
événement convivial accessible et c'est
aussi une des qualités de cette période
1900 finalement avec quelques
accessoires on arrive à être dans
l'ambiance
donc là pour l'occasion les personnes
qui viendront costumes et bénéficieront
d'un tarif réduit
donc c'est une manière aussi de
participer à la journée et
il y aura pour valoriser toutes ces
personnes un défilé à 16h alors s'il
fait beau autour des miroirs d'eau sinon
nous irons dans l'orangerie qui vient
tout juste d'être refaite
un beau programme ah oui un beau
programme et de belles activités
rejoignez nous merci que se leurrer ça
me dit alors pour rappel le château de
breteuil reçoit ses hôtes de l'année
1900 le dimanche 9 juin aux horaires
d'ouverture du site depuis plus de 20
ans la ville d'andrésy célèbre l' arrêt
la nature la 22e édition de sculptures
en il a débuté le 17 mai jusqu'au mois
de septembre vous pourrez découvrir les
nombreuses oeuvres sur les quatre lieux
de l'exposition marylène gyapi chine et
nicolas d'andré artistes nationaux et
internationaux se retrouvent andrésy
depuis 22 ans
il célèbre la nature à travers leurs
oeuvres originales
chaque année nous essayons d'amener de
nouveaux artistes de nouvelles visions
de nouvelles perspectives
mais en même temps on est toujours dans
cette continuité de célébrer ce rapport
à la nature la maison du moussel se voir
ollier au sophora japonais voisins à eux
deux ils forment une seule et même
oeuvre dans laquelle s'expriment les
souvenirs des habitants
les arbres engrange la mémoire du monde
et il a gardé dans sa mémoire
tous les souvenirs de larmes de joie et
de larmes de chagrin des habitants
d'andrésy donc nous sommes allés
enquêter dans les rues un peu au hasard
en eau d'andrésy en bas d'andrésy une
installation esthétique mais aussi
sonore à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur de
la maison
ils ont créé ces perles avec ces mots
d'andré zia je trouve c'est vraiment
plein d'émotions j'étais vraiment
scotché
je reconnais ma part cette heure plus
loin les sculptures d'une artiste suisse
laisse le soleil les mettre en mouvement
et j'essaie de transmettre en plus de la
nature aussi un certain optimisme parce
que les couleurs pures
c'est quand même ça ça donne de la force
dynamique un optimisme transmis au maire
d'andrésy qui inaugurait sa dernière
édition
il espère que son successeur fera
perdurer cette poésie encore longtemps
c'est la fin de ce cette culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]